it's clear perfect let's say pleasure to
meet you
is Charlie okay I mean I never know how
to how to refer to you you have so many
names it's fine you can call me Charlie
mr. 6.5 inch wiener or whatever you're
feeling about again the second one when
you blunder another mate I might go to
the second one
Oh were you watching the the warm-up
game I'm always watching so don't think
that you can get away with some shitty
play to begin from now on you're under
my permanent supervision all right good
what do I need I need to be whipped into
shape here I need to come in first place
this [ __ ] tournament if I don't come
in first place you're a bad teacher
that's well I know that's how the
Russian Russian teachers operate let me
capture your Kim from your stream if
that's okay and then mm-hmm go ahead get
started and in the meantime maybe you
can tell some of my viewers sort of what
what you do what your videos are about
I've been a fan for awhile but maybe
just a quick quick summary of what makes
you awesome
well sweep in yeah I do a lot of stuff
on YouTube primarily trust content so
you'll probably see on display today
that I'm pretty [ __ ] nasty at this
game just a wide assortment of games sex
toy related content just general rants
and talks a whole bunch of different
things you never know what to expect
mm-hmm well I'm expecting some grand
master level chess today or it's called
its cupboard okay I think I got your Kim
and let's see oh oh I have to be on the
actual screen don't I
is when I switch to the live chesses oh
it has to be probably a different
browser ok sorry give me another moment
all right well feel free to start
another game in the meantime obviously
oh yeah buddy plate lunch since you
played such an awesome first game yeah
I'm already getting slapped around don't
even worry about that all right in the
meantime I'm gonna follow you so you
have the white pieces actually you have
a better position than it might appear
special since you've captured a pawn
with check mm-hmm
almost didn't see that I was gonna make
a real shitty move my guess is you're
gonna defend the pawn on c2 that's
something that happens when you know I
don't know how to say this in a good way
when you're pretty shitty at chess oh
thanks I didn't mean that to be on the
record that's that's the right way of
saying it that's how you teach me that's
how I learn best good good then we're on
the same page so you paid attention to
that C to pawn and not to the Queen
sometimes that happens we'll work on
that but here you have to try to
understand what blacks threat is what is
it
going to this e to pawn or is it yes
he's not threatening it immediately
because you're defending of the Queen
but he wants to develop his Bishop to
have five chase that stupid Queen of
yours away and then capture on c2 with a
knight okay so you have to find a way to
preemptively either defend that square
on to which the bishop wants to go or
give more protection to the c2 pawn
either of the two should basically do
the job you have one move that does both
at the same time and if you find it I
think you'll be teaching me from now on
a move that protects both the f4 pawn
and the C to both the f5 square onto
which blacks Bishop wants to go to and
the c2 blowing okay well I don't think I
see it but would moving Bishop to d3 be
a decent move to protect that and it's
very decent very decent yes the other
move I was thinking was 93
and now hmm Oh so see he thinks he's
just playing you but that's interesting
he was so sure you're gonna miss a fork
there that he already basically free
moved it okay so let me add capture so
he's pinning your Queen to the bishop
mm-hmm and his eye is that if you move
your queen away he's gonna take your
bishop but what he's missed is that you
there's a certain square you can move
your queen to such that he has greater
things to worry about than taking her
bishop
your task is go by that square these are
going the beasts of him absolutely and
snapping off a pond while you're at it
and whatever city he's in is gonna have
an earthquake when he realizes you found
that move that's what I like to hear all
right so I finally got your amazing face
on cam so yeah I was thinking we could
do sort of a mix of several things it's
entirely your show whatever it makes you
learn the best observing your games and
we can do sort of an instructional
component where I show you some
strategies some openings etc sort of
wide open to whatever you had in mind
yeah I'm really uproot whatever man
whatever you feel most comfortable with
is the move here just take rook put on
Chuck yeah thank you I don't know if you
had your lunch but take the rook and
maybe even take another one if he moves
the King the people at your level
sometimes just seeing the free stuff and
sometimes it's just offered to you like
an all-you-can-eat buffet which it's
being right now it's just a free day
right now yeah he's like flying an
airplane it's got too much fuel so he's
just dumping some of it except it's not
how it works in chess okay so oh wow so
he wants to trade the Queen's - is that
it is that a advantage for me right now
absolutely so grab that Queen and grab
as many pieces off the board as you can
when you are up this much material and
you're currently up let me count orokin
the knight sorry I'm not usually up at
rook in a knight with other grandmasters
so I had to pause for a second like I
said other grandmasters kind of already
bringing me in that wing
ah so now you have another trade that
you can make and it takes more material
off the board do you see it is it the
knight for Bishop it is so take that off
the board and the last sort of oh my god
he's not even taking you're right oh hey
this is now going to Southern absolutely
you want to be a glutton in chess and
he's probably gonna give you a check and
think he's really cool no he's gonna
attack your knight so once you finished
this game I'll sort of explain the
principle behind wanting to trade as
much as possible in your up pieces but
for the time being I'll let you focus
okay so would the move here now be drop
tonight back to e5 yes I'm in check
precisely and then you have sort of one
last fold which is to develop your other
pieces uh that rook and the bishop you
have in the corner over there hmm are at
the moment not doing anything so you
want to open them up and put them on
squares where there at least breathing
okay sort of free bishop would you move
the b-pawn up to like be for b3 I would
move it to b3 okay so it's protective
its protected and then when you develop
the Bishop to a3 that pawn on b4 would
have been blocking the bishop so it
would have been restricting its access
to the diagonal if that makes sense okay
so what he's offering you more free
stuff I don't think he's learned his
lesson
yeah trust me I've made this mistake
before he's probably getting coached by
a lesser GM right now no I don't think
there are too many I'm one of the
Miles's GM's he's offering you a draw am
I seeing that right oh yeah I see that
wow that's that's disgusting disgust is
this someone from the chat right now
what is this garbage and he now he's
seeing that you are filled with
confidence in your ability to when he
declines okay all right so what do you
want to do now do you want to just go
through another game like that or do you
want to do something a little different
what is the like let's say I signed up
for your premium only fans chest lessons
what would you take me on next
there's some Trackman netiquette so I
think a mixture of things would be the
most appropriate after we look over this
game really briefly we can play maybe
one more sort of warm-up game so you're
in the zone and then after that I think
one thing we can start with and this is
sort of a fail-safe way to start
improving and I've looked over some of
your games so you're not definitely not
a complete beginner you sort of have the
very basics down which makes my job a
lot easier we can start by looking at
some openings and through the lens of
those openings I can try to show you
sort of the strategies and the tips that
are just a little bit above baseline
level if that makes sense yeah that
sounds good to me man so just really
briefly I mean you played such an
amazing game that I really don't have
much criticism which is unusual but just
from a general perspective the reason
that you want to trade pieces when you
are up so much material is just because
if you go to the if you're on that game
right now that you played against the
wall known player twenty to thirty for
one of the biggest in the business right
now from what I was doing absolutely
from the country of Gibraltar actually
Gibraltar hosts one of the biggest chess
tournaments every year believe it or not
it would be the founder honestly yeah
it's I think it's it's the king of Spain
crossed over the border so on move 14
you see that he played Queen ta had he
moved his king up to e7 and you can
actually if you have the game open as an
analysis you can you can make the move
on your board you would have had a very
very strong move just as a tactical warm
up for you could you spot the best move
for white in that position if he didn't
move queendom yeah but instead moved his
King up it just reset hold on shine and
after this I'll be inviting it for an
analysis board just this is just the
only comment I have about this game okay
so if you didn't move Queen and move
King up it just take the rook right so
that would be you know I would give you
a c-plus for that which in Russia is a
where I I was born I don't know I'm
sometimes full of [ __ ] I was born in the
Bay Area
but you know I come from the Russian
tradition of coaching that's a pretty
good great but you have something even
better believe it or not so if he moved
this king up without changing his Queens
be exact move you did believe it or not
you did in that better move is even
checkmate see if you can spot it move in
this multiverse you move King to d7 you
said E 7 yeah and that's the only legal
move available for the King Oh red and
you have and it's it's not that common
to have a checkmate in the middle of the
board but notice that your queen is
guarding all of the Kingsborough retreat
squares
it's the Knight to d5 beautiful I I
don't know why they hired me to teach
you I mean I think you've mastered it I
just loaded it almost immediately yeah I
mean that you were waiting for me to
actually see it to verify so would you
catch up exactly and that's one of the
key tenets that I'm gonna be sort of
reinforcing is when you see a move and
there's this common chess maxim when you
see a good move look for a better bumble
what does that mean oftentimes you want
to almost hold yourself back and you
want to do that for two reasons one of
them is what you see in front of you
sometimes your brain just spots a better
move and sometimes the people are you're
gonna be playing against set traps and
you're at the level where you have to
almost force yourself to think more than
you would normally think in order to see
those traps I mean once you play chess
for a certain amount of time it becomes
subconscious like you smell a rat
whenever your opponent offers you
something for free but you have to sort
of almost force yourself to get into
that habit if that makes sense
you're looking a little deeper okay I
get you and finally why would you trade
pieces when you're up materials so if
you imagine another multiverse as he
said where the two Knights disappear as
do his two bishops as do one pair of the
ropes okay so you're just left with a
broken abyssion would that position in
your mind be easier to win than what you
see in front of you after the Queens are
traded
for me personally probably not just
because I'm so notorious for missing
like easy checkmates regardless of the
pieces so I'm typically a little
hesitant to trade just for that reason I
feel like I need like the whole [ __ ]
army to get a checkmate on someone it's
like in some of these games totally but
if I would if I was a better player than
yeah that definitely be a lot more
advantageous totally understood I mean
we could even maybe start with that like
a little bit of a crash course into how
to win when you have let's say just up a
rope where you have a rope against the
king with some pawns what are the
strategies to actually finish them off
without having a whole army that's
pretty helpful for you to know okay so I
guess maybe you can play one more game
just as a warm-up and then we can move
on to the kicking your ass face okay
that sounds you that's my favorite phase
mm-hmm and for those asking this is
Daniel NART how do you say it in our
disk in there and it's key there shitski
will also be suitable I would never say
that about myself
he's also streaming if you want to see
him making fun of me on stream and
likewise vice-versa on my stream you can
follow the command and thank you Charlie
by the way this is a big big privilege
for me so I appreciate it that's the
last nice thing I'll say to you so savor
it okay cool I was going for her
scholars checkmate I believe yes except
he doesn't seem to notice that you
develop your knight and I think you Cara
mentioned this in the opening okay so
where is his night heading I believe he
wants to go to the g5 Square yeah
prevent him from doing that and you're
gonna drive your opponent nuts very soon
you can use your pawns exactly I didn't
even need to tell you how hmm that's
called alexis now as Sensei Hikaru
mentioned you can develop your pieces
when in doubt bring your pieces out onto
central squares usually start with the
Knights and that's sort of the most
straightforward part of the game exactly
good move okay so then it's just a
matter of just reading these pieces so
with pawn to d5 be worth anything
or should I not even bother well I guess
not I would play pawn to d6 so fond of
d5 he would capture it I I'm assuming
you want to sacrifice it to accelerate
at the speed of develop
but every pieces but it's too early for
that you wouldn't normally sacrifice
until you have all your pieces out okay
so he's made an interesting move here so
this is a situation I'm talking about is
this a situation where trading might be
something to consider is it just
something where I just moved the Queen
and just retreat definitely trade and
after the game I'll we'll analyze why
that's the case but for now definitely
take a night because if you moved your
queen he would have taken your knight
and then you would have had to ruin your
pawn structure which is a fait there do
not want to meet so now you have several
good moves you could work on bringing
that f8 bishop out by moving one of the
pawns out of the way or you could even
activate that night you have already
developed you could put it on an even
better Square is that better square the
d4 square it would be the D forcefully
yes and while you're at it you're
attacking the Queen forcing the Queen
and move showing him who's the boss
since her bow fist so that's I mean yeah
I made this one a long time ago back
when fisting was still cool if it ever
was some would argue it was yeah I have
an account like that Oh Queen a3 so what
comes to your mind uh moving tonight to
c2 is what I think he's actually set a
very devious trap for you if you take
the knight on c2 he gives you a check
with the Queen on a4 and he's exacting
not only your king but that very same
night which just took the pie and that's
work so you have several options you
could cover the diagonal on which the
Queen could check you in one of several
ways I would recommend that or you could
simply proceed by developing your king
side so that Bishop on f8 and working on
getting your King safe okay this -
knowing that he wants to go to the a
Foursquare to put me in check is it
worthwhile to just preemptively move a
pawn up to block it absolutely no and I
would do that even by attacking the
bishop on d5 while you're at it
that's exactly what I would do and he
needs to be careful because if he moves
the Bishop to c4 then you can already
take the pawn and a fork his Queen and
rook I don't think this guy wittingly
set the trap to be honest with you but I
think it was byproduct of his genius I
wouldn't count out Dave her neighbor
just yet yeah I think he's admitted his
last name
Kasparov or his hyphenated last name was
part of Carlson yeah so he's seen it
well this guy's basically a god so now I
should go back to developing on King's
side right the F bishop I would
recommend that yes okay so a situation
like this would it be moving the G pawn
to g5 I would that's a great move and
that's even better than moving at one
square because notice that knight on h3
they say Knights on the rim are grim and
the reason why is because the knight is
no prospects you're actually you can
actually win that night right now if you
so desired of course yes is just pushing
the pawn in order to go it is and is
Knight yeah his Knight his trust he can
give the knight up for maximum one pawn
and that is not a good trade okay so he
counter-attacks your knight mm-hmm
bastard
what a devious Spaniard fight so yeah so
I was gonna ask the I could move Knight
T well yeah I could move Knight to e2
for free right like that's an open tile
everybody isn't something there no go
ahead that's also a check and then you
can take his Knight
now you'll got a PP you're gonna have to
be careful in regards to making sure
that Knights stay safe because it's
clearly not maintaining social
distancing with White's pieces but you
know it has its prospects it has enough
squares to where your opponent's not
gonna trap it but you see what the
danger is right that Knight is stock
amidst you know the enemies
and I think David neighbors beginning to
question his existence right now yeah so
him moving rook up I think the only tile
I can even really go to is that a four
tile to protect with a pawn and at worst
trade with Bishop Wright I would not be
a bad man but this is a situation so I
called tunnel vision where you look at
the night right and the night is being
attacked oh [ __ ] I got it with the money
but you haven't even better move if you
look at his King his King is wide open
it's got only pawns in front of it as
cool is is you know somewhere in
Timbuktu doing god-knows-what
you can open up his King with a check
here you're picking the pawn take that
modern here you're actually very close
to delivering the checkmate here and
after he takes with the King which was
forced you could follow up with another
check to expose how weakest King is here
with the Rooker with the Queen does it
matter which one it does if you check
with the Queen he just might take it
with his bishop that's on c1 so if you
were to check the Queen I would take
that bishop first and then check with a
queen or you can check with the roof
it's your choice yeah well let's let's
see where this goes let's see how the
notorious devar neighbor responds okay
so he's moved his King back attacking
your knight and time to deal with that
night I would do the simplest here and
exchange it yeah man free up the left
side of the board there to push Queen
exactly yep Knight take C 1 and in
general it's a good practice before he
moved it he's on to a t-square that's
like past past your 6 ring to just look
at what squares your opponent's
controlling to make sure you know the
square his piece is controlling doesn't
correspond to the square you want to pay
a piece fine now there was something I
was thinking there before making that
trade since I had night on e 2 couldn't
could I push look to e 1 because it be
protected which would force him to go
back to that same square I really not
get to forcing in
you mean rook to g1 with Czech t1 sorry
well it would have forced him to take
the night on e - which is not the best
option Thank You chess for their faith
and he would have just captured your
night so it's almost checking it if that
square we're defended that would have
been a good move but well I've noted it
we'll talk about it okay a good sure now
you can follow up with your previously
desired Queen mo if they you love so
much
yeah we're going to do my best work you
sleep with this move I mean this is
squeegee five is like in your and all
your dreams okay this is a freebie right
now this guy's giving me the game I
don't know if he's gonna be your
neighbor I'm full of these funds you're
gonna exit the call pretty soon you're
among friends now okay so his king is in
deep [ __ ] basically to put it in chess
terms it's it is no defenders and now
you're gonna do what's called attacking
you're gonna bring your pieces out onto
squares that aim to deprive the king of
all of its remaining squares so what is
the king's escape route right now where
can it run to don't we really run to the
right side of the board right now so
could you take away that right side of
the board with either your queen of your
Bishop the e2 square specifically could
you put it under under the control of
one of your pieces yeah moving the
Bishop to g4 would stuff that as would
moving the Queen h5 right mm-hmm
so yeah that was gonna be my question so
initially like when this first came here
like on the screen I was thinking Bishop
to h3 to put him in check and then
moving the queen up is that like the
wrong order does that not matter it's
the wrong order because it allows the
King to escape a check is not good just
focus to check it allows the King to run
to the center of the board where it's a
little bit safer surrounded by rooks so
I would make one of those two moves I
would actually bring the Queen one site
one square to the left in order to keep
that G file under the rooks control if
you play Bishop g4 now you're actually
threatening checkmate in one move and
well he can't stop it it's actually
quite difficult to stop it
okay I see so it's another big problem I
have I guess I go I see like certain
things but I'll go very out of order
like I wouldn't have even registered
that by moving the bishop first that I
would block my own room from having that
Lane uh-huh well he's he's continuing
his African campaign and he seems to be
forget it yeah nice exactly so perfect
very well done
that was a good game um let me open that
game up and I can actually invite you to
an analysis board we can start by
looking over that game and maybe I can
make a couple of things clear that's
good to me then and then we can go from
there so turbo this is a little bit of a
glitch um analysis feature but hopefully
it'll work let me know if you got the
invite to the to the board there we go
oh can you try to to make a move like in
this position just a random move
oh yeah here oh my my white or black and
for white okay just so I can see whether
the moves are relayed yeah push pawn d4
okay I didn't see that there might be
some sort of maybe I need a pass you the
ownership and do you see me like moving
pieces yep I just saw you move Queen
Queen g5t four okay maybe in a chest way
thank you will do yeah I mean I think
we've we've got the analysis future
pretty maybe I can just make the moves
cuz I don't seem to be seeing your most
for whatever reason I wonder why that is
so right just I'll take I'll pick this
year I'll get a little backseat action
it alright so don't worry I'll still
love pester you with questions
essentially Queen e7 you played which is
actually not a bad move and my guess is
you were trying to protect that pawn on
f7 is that an accurate assessment of
this move
yeah so when I see someone especially at
this level most people go for that
scholars checkmate like all the time so
I like to put Queen there because I
think it frees it up a little bit and it
protect interesting so thank you for
Queen as I was gonna say think of your
Queen as a king and then I was gonna
that's
comparison but think your queenís as
someone that you know it's like a
specialized force you want to employ the
queen only for the most elite of tasks
like giving checkmate or defending
something particularly important that
cannot be defended by any other pieces
your knight on f6 is basically blocking
the Queen from accessing the f7 square
or the f7 pawn right yeah so you
actually don't need to reinforce the
defense with the Queen you can basically
just develop let's say with the move
Knight c6 and I understand the fear in
your mind that always gonna check me me
let me give this a little bit more
protection but the problem with quitting
your Queen here is that in terms of
adhering to the basic opening strategy
of developing your pieces do you see
what the problem this move creates in
terms of developing your Kings side yeah
Bishop out without moving another poem
exactly ends it's a cascade effect
because if you move that bond yeah okay
no big freaking deal I'm gonna move this
pawn you see this Knight and f6 it's
lost the support of a pawn so now you've
linked Queen d7 to lighten your load and
you've actually made your load a lot
heavier now the queen is too actually
tied down to the knight it can't move
around so you want to make sure that
your development is as unburdened as
possible knight c6 he will probably play
d3 what would be a good continuation in
this position good developing move would
it be getting the bishop towards the
middle of the board yep and what Square
particular comes to mind
d6 so the mistake of this move is the
same actually as the mistake of Queen d7
look at this other bishop exactly so
Bishop c5 is the most coherent sort of
developing move you could also play
Bishop e7 that's also fine and then you
would play d6 you would Castle and you
develop this Bishop to either a 6 or g4
so the key takeaway is when you're
developing your pieces try not to put
them you know try not to create an
elephant on the chest kind of situation
where you can't do up your other pieces
because some piece of [ __ ] Bishop is
sitting on it
okay yeah see that's not even Blake I
don't even consider that that's
definitely something I need to pay more
attention to god damn and like I i'll
definitely burn you with sort of a lot
of things i'll you know and and as you
can probably tell I talk way too much
but it's it's sort of a matter of
internalizing what you think is the most
important and you know like sifting
through what I say some things are gonna
remain some things we can review at a
later time but it's totally fine that I
know I'm saying sort of a lot of tips at
once so okay so let's look at the
Gateway d7 now you played aged six which
was an amazing I don't know how you came
up with this way of stopping the Knights
of g5 it was almost like a Grand Master
advised you it was actually came to me
in a dream this is something I've always
talked about and thought about I always
knew it'd come in handy at some point
I'm just happy I was in front of a Grand
Master today well you you impress that
particular grandma so much he's
soliciting lessons from you so you
develop your night and here you have the
question of whether to take the night
now what would be an alternative that
comes to your mind is tempting like what
what was your initial thought here uh
well if I didn't take the night I'd lose
the Queen right so well I mean I guess
you could push the night to d4 cuz then
you threaten his queen actually not a
bad move at all sorry that could cut you
off that's something I thought about but
I just don't really ever know if that's
worth the trade Queens like that cuz
again like I am just super like
oblivious to a checkmate so I always
want to have like as many pieces as
possible towards the end game mm-hmm
yeah you want to have the army to - yeah
alright that's totally understandable
and I'll introduce you so have you heard
of calculation that the concept of
calculation in chess well yeah I've
definitely heard of the word calculation
yeah it regards the go I never notice
calculate yeah what does a calculate or
well I never use that in math class so
calculation in chess specifically refers
to the anticipation of your opponent's
moves and the be thinking through of
chess sequences as far as they will so
grandmasters are often oh how many moves
ahead do you see right
I get this question all the time how
many moves ahead to Grand Master so you
know what I like you've probably heard
that question thrown around and that
really depends on the position but here
I can tell you that the move 94 is a
good one because I've calculated several
moves ahead and let me show you the
variation that I've calculated so if he
takes his if he takes your queen what
are you doing oh then I take his queen
then I take his queen with check he's
got to take your knight and now I'm
almost sure that you're very tempted to
take his knight is that accurate yeah
that's what I was saying there but try
to look at the whole board you have
actually a better move than even taking
this knight on e7 this Knight is
imprisoned in in San Quentin can you do
anything else while this Knight is
trapped it could take the knight on h3
with the bishop and you should and
you're also attacking the rook so you're
attacking two pieces at the same time
the knight and the rook he's got to give
up one of them if he moves the Roky take
the knight he can't actually evacuate
his night with a narrowest of margins
and now you take his rook and your upper
rook for a piece that's called an
exchange you're up in exchange the rook
is more valid with the piece you're
familiar I think with like approximate
p-values rook is more valuable knight in
a bishop which are about equivalent at
cetera right mm-hmm so if you're up a
rook for a piece also look at his pawn
structure I was gonna make some
insensitive in like World War 2
reference but I decided not to
anyway resembles Roman ruins or the
Colosseum let's say right let's take
something that everybody will appreciate
and agree upon which is not easy to do
these days but essentially 94 would have
been a good move but I realized why I
didn't play it you could have also moved
the Queen back and the problem with this
move maybe you could explain that to me
and in terms of the Roman ruins that I
just mentioned what happens after he
takes your knight
well I have to take with the pawn
because if I take with the Queen then I
just trade Queens right so that my
structure gets [ __ ] up kind of like
what his did exactly and you can't take
with the Queen at raping I know you
don't like to but it's the same thing
your structure is just as [ __ ] okay so
that is the reason why you take his
knight now
there is an opening principle that you
don't want to move the same piece more
than once in the opening and the reason
people tell you that is because you know
you don't want to eat the dessert before
dinner you want to make sure all your
pieces are out before you go [ __ ]
around with one of them now
that's not always the case and there's
exceptions to every single rule
sometimes you do want to move a piece
twice if your opponent blunders the
Queen in the opening and taking that
Queen involves moving your knight twice
then you want to take the Queen but keep
that in mind if your opponent is moving
his pieces around without developing
some of them it's probably a bad idea
okay okay that makes sense that makes
sense so I think we can actually begin
and if you're feeling pumps you know you
can play at any moment I'm sensitive to
the fact that I'm sort of I don't want I
don't want to be just lecturing you so
totally your call on that I'm ready to
rumble if you want to get after it okay
so what you want to do one more game
whatever you're feeling myself oh yeah
let's let's do this let's talk briefly
about how to convert positions when like
let's say you have just a rook and then
we can because then you won't be afraid
to go into those end games and then
you'll basically have all the tools you
need if that sounds good to you so let
us let me actually paste in a okay this
is like a very high-tech maneuver that
I'm making here so let me know if you
see this position in just about a
moment's and okay let's do let's do a
position like this setting copying in a
pacing right now all right
set position Oh amazing do you see the
position yeah see this is the extent of
my knowledge of just I know how to set a
position on chess that how can you flip
so on do you know how to flip the board
so you're facing white nope get out of
here
I'm just on top if you hover over to
where the gear is this is super
intuitive I don't know how you didn't
realize this if you hover over to the
gear two more little little I don't know
how to describe them little pieces of
[ __ ] will come up and the bottom of them
is Flipboard oh okay so you don't
actually click on the gear I guess no
you just hover the gears like a magnet
for weary travelers okay so we have a
sample position with white to move now
what you're facing white so white spawns
are going do you see the arrow spiny
chance yeah and blacks going this way
but we both want to promote our pawns
obviously as you can see your upper rope
so white should be winning here but
actually should be - winning is very
long bridge to cross so when you look at
this position what comes to mind how
would you play this out his wife what
moves sort of what ideas what strategies
do you come up with when you look at
this so I guess the way I would start
this in this situation would be able to
start with moving the pawn - up to g4
mm-hmm I try I ultimately try to get my
rook to the left of the pawns away I'm
just covering like F so I'm both
protecting a pawn and attacking the
pawns on the other side so am i pointing
the arrow correctly or to the left of
the board right there that's why I would
have moved to f1 and then I'd push them
up yup and you're also cutting off the
king so in terms of the order of things
the question is do you play rook up one
first or do you push the pawn first one
of those moves allows blacks king to
cross a certain zone and stop the pawn
the other one doesn't so which move
would you actually start with you'd want
to start with the rook that cut off that
lane beautiful you want to start with
the ruffle
cutting off the king now black is only
one option he's got the last of his
troops he's got to start pushing the
pawn you start pushing yours and the
problem is if you just close your eyes
and pray for the best
something really terrible is gonna
happen what happens in this situation
what is black to what it's queen first
yes and not only to oh I can get Queen
to accept I can't because I'm a Czech
and it's also a fork so just a brief tip
for you Queen Forks can be the hardest
to spot when you're not too experienced
with chess like you see that it's sort
of hello my math teacher would be so
proud of me no find the cosine of this
angle yeah Oh God never again
and they say chess is similar to math
absolutely not
basically these long Forks okay now I
need to get rid of those errors because
they're distracting our hearts a spot
you know the Queen from a1 attack of g7
or if you had a piece somewhere on H a
so that's when I say look at the whole
board that's kind of what I mean if that
makes sense look at both sides of the
board all of the pieces because a queen
from a6 is just as effectively attacking
upon that sits on the other side of the
board as let's say a knight that sits on
b6 okay so to prevent that I'd want to
have I would have I would have wanted to
move the rook up at some point yeah well
the best thing you can do is actually at
this point you can stop respond from
progressing any further how I guess I
just moved the King up right kids that I
just take the Queen when he promotes
very nice very nice and if he pushes his
other pawn then what do you do that I
pushed my pawn okay let's say I push the
pawn you promote to a queen now just to
some practice could you checkmate me
from this position with the white pieces
you can just since I'm not seeing your
moves for some reason you could just
tell me the most and I'll execute them
mundum on the electric chair
I'd take the pawn on a two because I
don't think I could get a checkmate with
just a queen on a king right is that is
that even like possible it is I've ever
seen it it actually is I can show you
how to do that but this is a very good
beginning you you don't want this fun
sitting in there nightmares just take it
first
you have all the time in the world to
checkmate okay I'll play King t6 oh I
think I have to give you ownership of
the board so I'm gonna saw me let me try
that and then maybe you can make moves
okay could you try making a move now
not as why it didn't work didn't work I
think it's your move that's why okay so
good oh let me see so what if you try
now no no it doesn't work okay yeah this
is flee to chess calm to improve their
analysis else's board is it it's not
amazing
okay so let's fast for it then in that
case yeah I'm sorry you'll just have to
tell me the moves so d5 so this was what
happens Queen King g7 do you still see
mine there right if you're making moves
right now I don't see it oh crap I made
it worse
I couldn't move oh there we go now I see
her move and I see her narrow but you
don't see mine right no I don't see you
I obviously didn't mean to move the rook
there I just tried to just do something
yeah yeah so you didn't see me move the
pawn um I see the pot I just didn't see
any arrows now I see an arrow and upon
in another arrow yeah awesome so I think
this is good we both see each other's
most okay
it's like sounds good then yeah so
basically let me recreate and you
actually see me moving no mm-hmm let me
just recreate the position we had I'm
not making actual moves so here here
blah blah blah and King t6 okay so
continue from this position okay so from
here I would have probably pushed rook
up okay bring my king up
hanck it moves defending the rope I'm
gonna push my pawn hmm that's not how
you treat grandmasters unacceptable so
this is what this situation I get in I
just keep so what I'm aiming for is to
push you into a corner but I feel like I
always go about it in like the most sub
optimal way so is what I'm doing right
now even like the right way of
approaching that it's not a wrong way of
approaching ice I have I haven't
gathered enough information to tell you
whether you're doing it in a shitty
manner yes so so far you're actually not
doing a bad job I'll put it that way I
need a couple more moves from you
I need more pieces of evidence if you
know what I mean yep okay that's exactly
good
that's how okay so you decide to take
the pawn which is fine you don't
strictly need to but not bad
okay
how far oh yeah that's typically how I'd
play something like this I'd just be
begging for a [ __ ] draw well
eventually you'd find so let me let me
let me show you how how because you were
very close actually much closer than you
might think you have the exact right
approach here when you have a queen in a
rope you want to drive the King to one
over the four corner files this file so
I'm drawing the arrows this file this
file or this file the reason is
obviously so the King cannot move
further back one of the Queen's one of
the Queen's one of the pieces holds the
King down and cuts it off the other
gives the check so in this case if it's
white to move you want to get this Queen
with the rook still cutting the King off
onto this file onto the seventh-ranked
could you do that
could you maneuver the Queen up to the
seventh rank maneuver the Queen onto it
yeah get the Queen on to the seventh
ring that's your without losing the
ropes preferably mmm I don't if I push
the Queen to c7 they're quick nicking
just take I would take it but you can
the great thing about the Queen is you
can you can move it much further than
the Kings range look at so that I just
moved it like where let's say H five or
eight five literally basically anywhere
I would go here okay and the idea is to
put the Queen here okay right and notice
that I cannot go to one of these squares
so let's say go King c7 you can go ahead
and proceed with queen a7 check okay so
you'd want to go say that again sorry I
keep free
I have push-to-talk on a new key so I
push to a five then push to a seven
right to get the check which forces you
back to the eighth brink right that's
exactly right so here you would go Queen
a7 home yep we're still aligned and the
final move now the Queen is cutting the
King off so now the real Gibbs to
checkmate right yeah okay I see it now
perfect but that kind of helps me figure
it out cuz I guess when I'm in a
situation like that I'm thinking only
one move but for that I needed to to go
to
the a5 and then up to a seven to make
that mm-hmm
not something or typically think about
yeah and I'm also not always showing you
the most efficient like methods of doing
so I'm showing you sort of the simplest
ones the ones that you can use to sort
of follow a formula and here like here I
would personally made in a different way
I would do like a side mate I would go
not to confuse you further but I would
do like I would do this and checkmate
here that's like you oh you don't see
that I didn't see that one crap I wonder
what so you don't see me moving around
now no I'm gonna take a guess did you
from that position did you move king
there Queen to d6 I moved rook to e7 so
let me let's see if I can it should
synchronize at some point let's see or
we might have to do a new new analysis
board rest assured I'm I'm writing a
letter to the programmers after this one
yeah let them know if you can't train
charlie it's just not even worth keeping
unwilling anymore Ben all right now no
this is yeah this happens every time I
try to analyze so I can let me try to
invite you to a new analysis board
you'll sure you should see another
invite pop up its her both this so I
think this one is damaged beyond repair
so I should have seen another invite now
let me try to set up the same position
we had hi welcome to the chest world's
okay so it was something like this copy
position and you see this it's a random
position right now but I'm about to set
a new one
okay do you see the position yep
so I would basically well what you did
was he basically cut off the king this
way I would basically cut the King off
this way and do this and sort of walk
the King over to the other side of the
board with checks it doesn't actually
matter which piece is doing the cutting
off and which piece is doing the
checking and I could give you a position
with two rooks let me show you that
through that lens then you'll get it
immediately what I mean you should see a
new position pop up in a moment and this
is gonna be downgraded out to two ropes
against the king if you get those
checkmate down you've discovered the
secrets of the universe that's what I
need right there and then the power of
God and all that should you [ __ ] she'll
be granted to copy position and let's
see
say your prayers do you see the position
yep amazing
so forget your king your king on d1 your
white king it doesn't participate in the
action you don't need it when you have
two rooks or a broken a queen or two
queens you do not need it all you need
are the two rooks and your strategy much
like with the rook and the Queen is to
drive the black King to the back rank
using one rook to cut off the rank and
one rook to give the checking and you
can slide the ropes around as necessary
so they're out of contact with the King
I don't know if any of that make sense
yeah if the King was in this situation
on the a5 square instead of the e5
square would they need to be on the same
ring for the rooks right it wouldn't be
the exact same strategy as the Queen and
the rook yeah Queen and the rook are the
same strategies just faster because like
let me let me show you how this is done
once and then you can kind of repeat it
so if I had a queen on g2 or a real
country - my first move would be the
same
rook g4 what is the purpose of this move
it makes it so he can't go towards the
king he can't go on the [ __ ] rink now
right I'm gonna attack your rook but big
[ __ ] you just moved the rook to the
other side of the board move it as far
away from the King as possible there we
go now if the King moves to the center
of the world
what would be White's next move we are
pushing up the h5 perfect now I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna blinking g5 and
this is where what I told you last time
about basically bringing this rogue out
of contact with the King comes into play
you don't want to give a check here I'm
gonna take your rub that is still made
Abel by the way king and rook against
King is a mate mate Abel situation thank
you got it for the raid but your task is
to bring the stroke to a square where
the King cannot reach it how would you
do that
would it just be sliding it to g1 then
I'll go King f5 bring it to the other
side of the board is my hint uh ok ok so
you'd slide it all the way over to e1
that's possible but I would actually
slide it although ever to be to again
you're thinking in terms of one move
don't be afraid to make 30 moves to
achieve what you need to achieve you're
not in a hurry so I would go rook g2 and
this actually causes a situation where
blacks King has to do damage so if I go
King e5 what can you now do well now I
can push up to the g5 square beautiful
and you but you've made a step forward
and if King f6 you can make a different
kind of accomplishment cutting the King
off one file further how can you do that
would that be dropping him back to h5
and then pushing up to h6 again you
should be teaching me that's exactly
what you should be doing so kingi 5
let's say rook c5 check I mean it took
me years to learn this checkmate I'm
still learning it actually we're
learning together then we are actually
the harder for your information I'm not
gonna teach you this today or ever but
well when you become a GM that's there's
a check Z with a night in a bishop so
imagine you have just a knight and a
bishop on the ward that might not be
mind-blowing to you might be lay out
whatever but that is actually a
checkmate Abel situation you can check
me with a knight and a bishop which to
many beginners sounds like what the hell
how can these two impotent pieces
combine to checkmate the King but they
can interesting yeah save that is like a
little birthday present or like a
graduation present when I'm up there at
the super Gian level
a two-hour lecture on how to check me
with night ambitious so to continue this
torturous process let's say the King
moves back to have six now where would
you put this row country five so I'd go
for that rook I'd move them to h5 so
here yeah so let's say I attack your
rook now well then I just drop them over
to a five and then push up to a six but
then so this is the one square you don't
want to put your rock on and of course
the because then you on cut the King and
I can go up here so you're almost there
which squares doesn't interfere with
that other book like yeah you just don't
want to let them do their goddamn job I
hope my steam will forgive me for four
usage of that term so let's say King F
six continue okay then age six four yep
and now this is the beautiful stage of
the game this is like two viola and
singing and you know in harmony push up
the b7 a yes checkmate
so the key thing that I think the only
thing you struggled with is the concept
that you can take many moves like you
can move this rook if you wanted it's
all the way to b5 okay mm-hmm it's like
foosball you move it all the way to one
side then immediately to the other side
if you know what I mean now okay you
have a situation where you can't go
rogue b7 big [ __ ] rook g5 r okay tree I
mean the king you can take as many moves
as you want and you can keep moving the
rope to the other side of the board
that's why roots are so powerful because
the king can't reach them in time you
know it's like outrunning a zombie